training Outdoors is to strength
training what sparring is to martial
arts a way to stress test your
performance let the natural environment
Forge your body into something stronger
try doing a pull-up from a tree branch
versus a pull-up bar when you do a
pull-up from a tree branch you need a
greater grip to hold on tougher hands
and the branch will vary in thickness at
different points and one hand might be
slightly higher than the other every
single set will be slightly different
building stronger connective tissue and
more robust motor patterns repetition
without repetition as Nikolai Bernstein
would say it's the same thing when trail
running in minimal Footwear the same
thing lifting logs and branches even
practicing calisthenics and movements on
uneven grassy terrain then there are the
elements training in the cold or the wet
or the Heat and the greater sensory
stimulation that comes from those Vistas
take your training outside and challenge
your strength in new ways subscribe to
the channel for plenty of content like
this